there's one girl within the dorm every
[ __ ] guy
fond over this chick like loved her to
[ __ ] death not because her
personality was dope not because of
anything else they just thought that she
was [ __ ] hot as hell personally
didn't think that she was that
attractive but to them she was she was
like a cheerleader very fit she was like
half chinese half white they should look
cross-eyed maybe that's why they were
like it but but they were thinking about
other things with those cross-eyed
exacts I did anything the biggest think
that bigger their mouth you'll probably
straining or something but you know
being a pretty person too I think that
the the lens of of what a pretty person
sees it's so different from everybody
else too especially because she's
cross-eyed yeah this girl I didn't I
didn't it's not that I didn't like her
it's just we didn't vibe very well
because I think she kind of predicated
her personality on her looks like she
didn't really have much to offer or talk
about aside from things about herself
it was very narcissistic right and I
didn't really blame her for that I kind
of blamed it on all the guys around her
so when she would walk into the dorm
every [ __ ] guy would act as if they
were on an island and they haven't seen
[ __ ] in years
they were walk oh how was your day doing
what are you doing today they would they
would try to make her laugh or she would
say something not funny at all and
they're just cracking the fun down and I
was just like the [ __ ] like the [ __ ]
anemia fine anyway she was she's not
saying anything and so when I would walk
by her I would be like hey just give her
a high in a wave right and then we just
move by I would say hi and then one day
we're all chilling in the dorm and we're
all talking and then she could she could
she asked to talk to me she takes me
aside I'm like what's up and I'm like
what's up she goes how come you don't
like me I'm like what what do you mean I
don't like you she knows how guys
actually get hot girls yeah she goes I
could tell you don't like me and I'm
like I don't I don't know what you're
talking about
she was like you don't she's like you
don't really talked to me you don't like
start up a conversation be like what's
wrong with me and I'm like yo nothing's
wrong with you like I'm I say hi to you
every time I see you right she goes yeah
but it's different I can tell it like
you have like an attitude I'm like
listen I at that point because I had a
girlfriend at the time I was
madly in love with ya so I looked at I'm
like I'll be real with you right she
never really talked to me after this I
was like ah be real with you I don't
know why you think you're so [ __ ]
special like I'm just I'm just chilling
like I'm just saying hi like I know
these other dudes when they come up to
you they're all like fawning over you
and you're used to that attention I
don't care about you like that I don't
know you like that yeah so I'm just
gonna say hi to you like if you want to
get to know me we could be friends yeah
let's do that so she took you as being
standoffish
and bad behavior because she has a
different standard of how guys treat her
exactly when someone wasn't in love with
her which they it was yeah you're right
it's their fault because cuz they're
actually friend-zoning themselves she
thinks oh these guys are so nice and so
cool we're all friends not knowing that
they all want to [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of
her of course and if you ask you she'll
be like nah we're friends no way you
know and then she sees you this [ __ ]
doesn't want to be my friend
yeah and like I said before I don't even
blame her I blame all those [ __ ] guys
yeah ruling over her for setting the
standard of what a normal human
interaction is you know you fell upon a
technique though that many people do not
know until they accidentally get there
was what that girl came up to you
because you made her self-conscious and
that's how you get hot girls I already
had like this girl I was in love with so
I know but that's that's that's what a
lot of dudes [ __ ] up on it is they're so
[ __ ] desperate dude yeah but I mean
yeah you don't have to be a dick just be
just center yourself yeah and then an
insecure sure you'll [ __ ] make her
insecure because you're not [ __ ]
doing what other guys doing and you know
what I think to which which kind of hurt
her feelings the most is that you had to
say like getting so [ __ ] special
though what cuz I was already irritated
like I'm not special like that don't
college I was like I don't know and I
was you think I'm harsh now what
eighteen year old David was way worse
like I didn't give up [ __ ] yeah
so now I'm like you're not that special
like you I already said all that [ __ ]
but when I look back at it the reason
why I think I was also upset was because
I think she thought fat chubby Asian
dweeby guys should be drooling over me
so why is this guy who was like geeky
fat and weird-looking isn't drooling
over me what's wrong yeah and that
already irritated me it's like [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] about you yeah you
know what I mean like I don't [ __ ] at
the time I was I was madly in love with
my 18 year old girlfriend I was 18 we
were in love you were just a [ __ ]
blip in the radar to me so it didn't
[ __ ] matter you know and I think it's
because her her [ __ ] was hurt because oh
this guy clearly he's gonna he's gonna
be drooling over me yeah and I didn't
like her thinking that she could had
that power over me because you don't I
don't give a [ __ ] I never really have
even the first girlfriend that I with
then I was with I didn't really like her
because she was the prettiest girl in
the school I liked it because of how she
made me feel you know she made me feel
that's so advanced you're so emotionally
intelligent I mean I grew up talking to
my mom all the time that's just a [ __ ]
like oh and you grew up in that hair
girl talk hell yeah I was wrong with my
whole [ __ ] life dude and I was too
but you were in them the difference the
women are more I was around were not the
way I think they're different man like
they didn't do the gossiping girl talk
all that stuff my mom [ __ ] hated
gossip my grandma was highly intelligent
she was more like a dude always wanting
a debate and talking about intellectual
[ __ ] and my yeah and my mom was just
working and very like to herself and if
she goes hang out with her friends and
I'm around like they're talking about
worldly [ __ ] so I didn't think then I
didn't have a maybe a good example of
like what most women are like you know
because of the women in my family were
different yeah and they didn't show that
side to the kids which I found out later
they do they did do it but they
compartmentalised what they did whereas
in other families that [ __ ] just went
out yeah you saw mom [ __ ] you know
doing this losing her composure doing
whatever like having her period days
whatever they saw the natural forms of
what a woman does mm whereas my house
they come they kept it separate they're
like don't bother the kids don't bother
the husband mm-hmm yeah yeah man like I
think I've always liked the emotional
connections because the first time I've
ever lost my the first time I lost my
virginity was with the girl that I had
been chasing in high school for three or
four years yeah so I think like that
type of sex that I had which by the way
was terrible sex uh-huh I didn't know
what the [ __ ] I was doing [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] she was doing that [ __ ] sucked
I wish it was like Mormon [ __ ] [ __ ]
threw a blanket type of sex and like you
know I mean I the religious very strict
you know like [ __ ] to like make a
child type of sex just very boring
because I don't know what I was doing
but because of that emotional connection
that I had with her I think that was the
type of high that I was always looking
for when it came to sex because after
her yeah when I I was just like you know
what dude like you keep trying to look
for love you just need to just date as
much girls as you can for number one for
stand-up experience so you have stories
to talk about yeah but to